this suit means something
it's not just protecting your body it's
protecting the universe ready captain
lightyear ready as i'll ever be to
infinity and
yeah we've got a breach in the privilege
thank you
let's get everyone home
you need my help negative are you
sure buzzed like i'm always sure
oh no
buzz lightyear mission log my mistake
has marooned us on this strange clinic
i need to make it right
hello buzz i am socks my mission is to
help you and i'm not giving up on my
mission i'm not giving nothing to you
great would you like a frosted snack
kick to celebrate negative
was like your mission log i plan to
finally finish the mission oh you're
talking to buzz no no one
here we go
are we going to crash no
well technically yes
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
what is going on
the what i hope you're ready for action
because all we needed was
for what you have to destroy the alien
ship
have a plan and i have a team do you
have munitions training partial so your
rookies oh boy we love to be rookies
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it
people people people let's go
did you hear that i don't hear anything
oh now i do
do this grab it it's the violation of my
parole
i think i need a bed oh no engage your
helmet that'll catch it
let's go finish the mission
we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
we can do anything you're not shouting
my ear oh yeah
[Music]
hey what's that noise come on don't
break my cat he's purring he likes it
sucks do you like that i do
huh